[Musique]
un jour ce sera le plus beau palais
du monde mais pour l'instant c'est un
chantier c'est une porte et comme
ça une fenêtre la différence est flagrante
mais pas à un de mes Nobles pour monsieur
duverney il y a deux jours le con  un imbécile
pensait qu'il traversait une
porte ouverte pour se rendre compte trop tard que c'était
en fait une fenêtre heureusement pour lui, il
a atterri sur quelque chose de mou
un jeune homme qui passait
devant pas si chanceux pour le jeune homme
trente mille constructeurs sont venus  ici tous
les jours pour construire des chambres des salons des cuisines des théâtres d'
un jour et des chapelles il y
aura 67 escaliers 1600 fontaines 2000
fenêtres 2000 fenêtres ce palais est mon
rêve ma vision mon obsession La beauté
partout des statues dans chaque pièce des
peintures sur les murs
tu penses que c'est de l'arrogance toi  're faux
rêves ne sont pas bon marché il y a un coût et
aussi un coût humain 60 livres pour un
lac brisé cinquante livres pour la perte d'un œil
trente livres pour un cheval je les ai vus
de mes propres yeux des charrettes arriver tous
les jours pour transporter  loin des morts est-ce que j'ai des
regrets est-ce que ça vaut le coup est-ce qu'un
homme mérite de mourir pour un tas
de pierre oui oui et encore oui car
c'est dans notre nature d'imaginer d'
inventer d'explorer de créer des monuments
pour la postérité
au cas où tu '  re demande Masuda Bernie
devrait faire un rétablissement complet à
la déception de sa femme et l'
ensemble du cordon
vous